die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport einen schönen guten
abendag von mir und das sind unsere
Themen Eindrücke aus dem Kriegsgebiet
unsere Reporterin war mit dem
israelischen Militär im
Gazastreifen Anerkennung für Soldaten
und Soldatinnen Deutschland soll einen
Veteranentag
bekommen und zweites Rennen zweiter
Podestplatz in Finnland lingt Lener ein
perfekter Start in die neue
Skisaison im Gazastreifen war heute der
Grenzübergang nach Ägypten nach zwei
Tagen wieder offen so konnten zumindest
mehrere hundert Ausländer und
Palästinenser mit zweitem Pass
ausreisen nach israelischen Angaben hat
die Hamas die Kontrolle über den Norden
des abgeriegelten Küstenstreifens
verloren die Versorgungslage bleibt
katastrophal Stefan
Schlösser auch in der größten Not bringt
der Fernseher ein bisschen Normalität in
einem Schutzraum tief im Inneren des
alkutz Krankenhauses in gasadt schauen
die Kinder gebannt auf den Bildschirm
der weil operieren die Ärzte nur noch
unter widrigsten
Bedingungen wir haben etwa 600
stationäre Patienten hier die
medizinisch versorgt und evakuiert
werden
müssen das Problem ist sicherzustellen
dass wir die Neugeborenen evakuieren
können weil wir haben etwa 40 Babys hier
die israelische Armee kündigte an bei
der Evakuierung von Säuglingen aus dem
schwer umkämpften schieferkrankenhaus zu
helfen nach Angaben des von der Hamas
kontrollierten Gesundheitsministerium
sind bereits Kinder gestorben nachdem
der letzte Generator ausgefallen ist
überprüfen lassen sich die Angaben
beider Seiten nicht während das ganze
Land im Ungewissen ist über den Verbleib
der entführten deutete Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu heute im amerikanischen
Fernsehen einen Fortschritt in den
Verhandlungen über die mögliche
Freilassung von Geiseln
an es könnte sein aber ich denke je
weniger ich darüber sage desto größer
werden die Chancen dass es tatsächlich
dazu kommt und das ist das Ergebnis des
militärischen Drucks auf die Führung der
Hamas unsere ZDF Reporterin Katrin
Eigendorf hat heute die israelische
Armee in den Norden Gazas begleitet hier
konnte sie sich mit eigenen Augen einen
Eindruck von einem Teil der Zerstörungen
machen und auch einen humanitären
Korridor sehen den die Zivilbevölkerung
für die Flucht in den Süden nutzen kann
und jetzt ist uns Kathrin Eigendorf aus
Tel Aviv zugeschaltet wie haben sie das
Kriegsgebiet
wahrgenommen also was zuerst einmal
auffiel war wirklich das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung wir haben Dörfer dort gesehen
die waren dem Erdboden gleich gemacht
also da ist nichts mehr übrig geblieben
von den Häusern die da gestanden haben
der Grund warum die israelische Armee
uns mitgenommen hat und uns die
Situation vor Ort gezeich zeigen wollte
ist vor allem dass sie klar machen
wollen dass sie es nicht darauf
abgesehen haben Zivilisten zu verletzen
sondern ganz im Gegenteil wir hatten
Gelegenheit östlich von Gaza Stadt einen
humanitären Korridor zu sehen ich würde
mal sagen in der halben Stunde die wir
da draußen sein konnten sind 1000 Leute
vorbeigekommen also man muss damit
rechnen dass es 1000 sind die sich noch
immer auf den Weg machen vom Norden in
den Süden und die israelischen Militärs
haben während wir dort waren auch immer
wieder Durchsagen gemacht und gesagt
wenn hier Menschen sind Israelis unter
den Menschen sind in diesem Zug dann
sollen die sich bitte melden denn das
sagen alle Soldaten übereinstimmend die
Geiseln sind nach der Beseitigung der
Hamas die oberste Priorität wirklich für
die israelischen Soldaten im
Gazastreifen das war schon
ein sehr umfassender Eindruck den ich da
gewinnen konnte obwohl man natürlich
sagen muss er ist ein Eindruck aus Sicht
der Armee die dort agiert wir können ja
nur mit der israelischen Armee in den
Gazastreifen gehen aber auch ich hatte
den Eindruck dass die meisten Soldaten
dort schon auch im Fokus haben die
Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen aber sie
sagen trotzdem bleibt Priorität die
Hamas zu zerschlagen und was sie
vermeiden wollen eben dass zu viele
Zivilisten zwischen die Fronten zwischen
israelische Soldaten und hamaskämpfer
kommen danke schön nach Tel Aviv für
diese Eindrücke aus dem Krieg danke
schön Katrin Eigendorf nach Deutschland
in
Essen sind vor einer Stunde mehrere
hundert Menschen für Frieden und
Versöhnung auf die Straße gegangen
aufgerufen dazu hatte eine Allianz aus
Parteien Gewerkschaften und Unternehmern
mit dem symbolischen Anzünden von Kerzen
warben sie auch für Solidarität und den
Schutz von jüdischem ben in Deutschland
und in Israel die Allianz verurteilt die
Terrorangriffe der Hamas gleichzeitig
fordert sie humanitäre Hilfen für die
Menschen im
Gazastreifen ein deutliches Zeichen
gegen Antisemitismus kommt aus
Frankreich allein in Paris beteiligten
sich mehr als 100.000 Menschen angeführt
wurde der Protestzug von
Spitzenpolitikern und den ehemaligen
Präsidenten sarzi und Oland seit Beginn
des Gazakrieges wurden in Frankreich
mehr als 1200 antisemitische Vorfälle
registriert darunter Gewalttaten
Pöbeleien und
Schmierereien Deutschland will nach
Medienberichten seine Militärhilfe für
die Ukraine im kommenden Jahr verdoppeln
demnach sollen die Ausgaben von 4 auf 8
Milliarden Euro steigen damit würden die
Verteidigungsausgaben 2,1% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts betragen etwas
mehr als das erklärte natoziel von
mindestens 2% der geplanten Erhöhung
muss noch der Haushaltsausschuss
zustimmen um die Leistungen von
Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu würdigen
wird in Deutschland wohl bald ein
Veteranentag eingeführt dafür zeichnet
sich eine breite Mehrheit im Bundestag
ab im Gespräch ist der heutige 12
november des Gründungsdatum der
Bundeswehr im Jahr
1955 Ines trums hat
Details feierliches Gelöbnis heute in
Berlin vor 0 Jahren wurde die Bundeswehr
begründet lange fremdelten Politik und
Gesellschaft mit allem militärischen die
Zeitenwende ändert das Ampel und Union
wollen einen jährlichen Veteranentag
einführen ich glaube das es ein Zeichen
ist der Gesellschaft Anerkennung für
einen Dienst zu leisten die Menschen die
in Uniform ihren Dienst leisten tun das
ja für uns D wir uns ja sicher fühlen
können denn viele tragen auch
Verletzungen davon seelische körperliche
und das alles anzuerkennen ich glaube
das ist eine Aufgabe die wir insgesamt
als Staat aber auch als Gesellschaft
erfüllen sollten öffentliches gedenken
für Veteranen mit Pomp und Publikum
gibt's beispielsweise in den USA oder
Frankreich deutschen Soldaten wäre
wichtiger generell gesehen zu
werden es geht nicht um eine Art
konfettien es geht um eine dauerhafte
Anerkennung und Wertschätzung für das
was Soldatin Soldaten Veteranin
Veteranen geleistet haben oder heute
noch leisten und ich glaube es ist
wichtiger denn je dass wir so einen
Veteranentag auf den Weg bringen deuts
gedenkt seiner Veteranen bislang eher
versteckt Gedenkstätte und Ehrenmal sind
für die Öffentlichkeit schwer zugänglich
ein Veteranentag keine gute Idee aus
Sicht der Linken wir wollen die
Bundeswehr aus den Auslandseinsätzen
zurückholen und wir wollen dafür sorgen
dass Deutschland nicht kriegstüchtig
sondern friedenstüchtig wird in der
kommenden Woche wollen Ampel und Union
Details festlegen wer als Veteran gilt
und inwiefern verbesserte
Sozialleistungen mit einem solchen Tag
ein herg gehen
sollen die Ratsvorsitzende der
Evangelischen Kirche Annette kurschuss
hat die demokratischen Parteien in der
flüchtlingsdebatte zu einem gemäßigteren
Ton aufgerufen es werde von Zahlen
gesprochen die runter müssen als ginge
es um eine mittelschwere mathte Aufgabe
wer von Migration rede rede von Menschen
vier Tage lang treffen sich die
Delegierten des evangelischen
Kirchenparlaments in Ulm dabei geht es
auch um den
Mitgliederschwund
beim Wintersport hat Lena dürnen Lauf
norber zweiter slalum Wettbewerb zweiter
Erfolg gestern im finnischen Levy da
wurde die Münchnerin ja zweite heute
schaffte sie wieder den Sprung aufs
Podium als drittschnellste Läuferin ja
und auch US Superstar Michaela Schiffrin
hatte allen Grund zum Feiern Mikaela
Schiffrin zwar in siegerlaune aber auch
mit tröstenden Worten für ihre
Konkurrentin Petra willowa Schiffrin
zeigt zwar einen gewohnt souveränen Lauf
mit dem sie die Spitzenposition
übernimmt doch dann profitiert sie vom
Einfädler von willova die als Führende
in den Finaldurchgang gestartet war
Schiffrin feiert damit ihren insgesamt
89 Weltcupsieg vor der Kroatien Leona
popot Lena dürfer spielt als vierte des
ersten Laufs zwar zunächst ihren
Vorsprung durch eine zu passive
Fahrweise am Ende reicht es aber doch zu
Rang 3 und damit zu einem nahezu
perfekten Saison
Auftakt im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußballbundesliga der Männer hat Union
bzw nein Entschuldigung hat Leverkusen
Union Berlin mit 4:0 besiegt und ist
wieder Tabellenführer alle Höhepunkte
des 11 Spieltags ab mititt naachzusehen
auf zdfheute.de und in der ZDF heute App
ja und in der Bundesliga der Frauen da
hat Wolfsburg zunächst die
Tabellenspitze übernommen durch den
souveränen 140 Sieg gegen die
Freiburgerinnen zweifache Torschützin
Eva por Wolfsburg schnürt die
badenerinnen regelrecht ein aus vielen
Chancen gelingt aber erst nach 35
Minuten das durch die Polin auf
Vorarbeit von Marina Hegering die auch
das 2: durch Vivi Endemann in die Wege
leitet
Endemann legt dann in der zweiten Hälfte
por den nächsten Treffer auf schließlich
macht Lena latwein das 4:0
Wermutstropfen für die Siegerinnen
Kapitänin Alexandra Pop scheidet
verletzt
aus und das war auch schon vom
sonntagsport beim Wetter gilt eine
aktuelle Warnung Dauerregen im
Schwarzwald und am Alpenrand die
weiteren Aussichten im Südwesten nach
einer kurzen Pause am Vormittag später
neuer starker Regen auch sonst häufig
Niederschlag nur ganz im Nordosten bis
zum Abend trocken bei 7 bis 16° starker
im Westen auch stürmischer Wind um : Uhr
meldet sich mariettaomka mit dem heute
journal hier übernimmt morgen Mitri
Sirin wir sagen danke und tschüss
wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start in die
neue Woche und geben ab zu schakuntala
und Berlin direkt